pour soi mais là messieurs caméra 66 ou
propose ce soir une émission sur le
vietnam
nous sommes à damas
nous en sommes déjà la deuxième alerte
au mois sept ou huit mirage au dessus de
nous maintenant à un libéral a été élu
dans lac saint jean les tard ce soir en
cette première de la nouvelle édition du
point beaucoup de mattila était partout
il a tout fait kern à doha la flamme des
grands journalistes
c'est une passion la télévision pour moi
le journalisme le reportage son intérêt
pour les médias est apparue très tôt
à 19 ans il se fait engager comme
annonceur à rimouski
un an plus tard de retour à montréal
il anime ma radio canada toutes sortes
d'émissions de variétés nous allons vous
présenter la chronique les actualités du
cinéma mais très vite pierre nadeau
prend le chemin du journalisme et à 29
ans en 1965 il est nommé correspondant
de radio canada à paris il se rend au
vietnam à deux reprises et en revient
avec des reportages percutant sur la
guerre en 1968 de retour au québec
pierre nadeau prend la barre des plus
grandes émissions d'information télé mag
le point et surtout le 60 écoutée par
plus d'un million de téléspectateurs
jean voulu faire avec le 61 magazine
serré nerveux joint d'ailleurs assez
fort la carte de l'émotion conflit
israélo-arabe renversement du président
allende au chili camps de réfugiés ou en
duras en 1970 quelques mois avant la
crise d'octobre au québec pierre nadeau
vaman débusquer dans un camp palestinien
de guérilla deux québécois du flq
vive la révolution socialiste québécoise
et internationale
il anime tous et interroge tout le monde
n'hésitons pas à bousculer ses invités
qu'est ce que vous avez fait quand vous
avez a prévu d'avoir tout ce qui se
passe est chic et ms en raison de
tractations en 1979 car nadeau kit radio
canada fonde sa maison de production et
conçoit émissions et documentaires pour
de nombreux réseaux en 1994 il est nommé
délégué du québec à boston mais il n'y
reste qu'une année décidément plus
journalistes que diplomate
il reviendra du canada pour y présenter
le magazine en jeu tout au long de sa
carrière il reçoit de nombreux hommages
dont
mu 1 le grand prix gémeaux de l'académie
de la télévision et du cinéma
entourée de sa fille pascale et de ses
petits enfants
le journalisme notre métier est souvent
décriée moi je trouve c'est un métier
qui est honorable c'est un métier qui
est beau geneviève asselin radio canada
montréal